mm Oh goose excuse you you just fart it
from your mouth ashes Miss America
please don't look away look towards look
goose don't look away stop ignoring me
[Music]
Thursday it is Thursday here on its
grace and there's still no real name to
this day that thirsty Thursdays thirst
think about it Thursdays basically I'm
just gonna give you tips on life tip
just the tip Thursday may be just the
tip Thursday day tea tea tea it's JT tea
the reckoning JT TT if you guys don't
know JT tea Jonathan Taylor Thomas who
was the heartthrob he's basically the
hairstyles of my generation and it
saddens me that you never experienced
that I went on my tumblr grace Helbig
tumblr calm and ask you guys what did
you want to learn how to do today and
someone said choose a career that is a
very heavy question here's my philosophy
choosing a career is like choosing a
significant other and here is why you
want to make sure that they're as
attractive in person as they are online
that when you talk about them to your
friends both you and your friends are
excited about it
they make you a better person sometimes
they buy you lunch you interned with
them in college and you just knew that
you would be together forever
they stimulate your brain vagina you
don't have to wear sexy sexy clothing to
get acknowledged when you wake up in the
morning you're excited that they're part
of your day sometimes they make you
breakfast the Google offices have anime
thing breakfast spread they monitor your
drinking don't drink at work unless you
blog for living links they remember your
birthday office birthdays are awkward
birthdays there's something you can see
yourself doing ten years from now your
family loves it and you couldn't be
happier where your family hates it and
you couldn't be happier
there's an opportunity for growth well
there you go there are some ways to
choose your career just like choosing a
significant other for the most part I
hope this was helpful
I don't know camp Takota calm is a
website that I think you would enjoy as
a human in this world existing for the
sake of pleasure and happiness
it's Gray's past 1 million subscribers
yesterday and I can't thank you guys
enough this has been an insane two and a
half weeks it feels like it's been two
and a half years thank you thank you
thank you continue to be on this stupid
dumb ride train with me I'm holding onto
a light that is burning my hand bad
choices but you made the right choice
being here with me maybe maybe not
you'll find out